listen I want to talk about the concept
of hitting the wall and here's what I
mean by hitting the wall no matter what
you doing life sports business moving up
the corporate ladder no matter what
you're doing you are going to hit a wall
by the way there's always gonna be walls
even when you're a billionaire there's a
wall even when you're the goat of
anything there's still about there's
always gonna be walls except you become
better at either climbing over the wall
or running through the wall because you
have an army following you as well right
you're not gonna be by yourself you
understand the concept of leverage
influence all that stuff together this
is what I'm gonna talk to you about I
talk to a lot of people who are about to
have a breakthrough right they're about
to have a breakthrough but they have
convinced themselves in here of one
thing and let me tell you what it is
they've convinced themselves that what
they're going through no one's ever gone
through before that their wall is bigger
than everybody else's wall that their
difficulty no one knows how hard it is
but you don't know what I'm going
through but you don't know my different
you don't know my family you don't know
my heartache you don't know my enemy you
don't know who I'm facing you don't know
this opponent he's so manipulative you
don't know how the industry is you don't
know how to market this you don't know
the company I'm a part you don't
everything that's said you don't know my
wife you don't know my boyfriend you
don't know my husband you don't know my
parents you don't know who I am my
difficulties are bigger than your
difficulties and that's why I can't
overcome these difficulties it makes
place up to you you know it's dangerous
you actually believe that because if you
actually believe it you are right
there's nobody else that can do any
convincing for you but it's in that
moment look at Hollywood do you think
everybody in Hollywood is a good actor
honestly I can name you 20 people that
are terrible actors who have had a
career of 20-plus years you can as well
but they persevered they believe they
belong in that space
even though how many auditions you think
that got passed up on you think in
basketball everybody's got a god-given
talent you think Steph Curry can jump
like LeBron James or Vince Carter I
would say Vince Carter's got god-given
abilities I don't know just have Kris
got the same kind of god-given abilities
as LeBron or Vince Carter or any of
these guys in baseball you think
everybody's got this perfect 20/20
vision like Ted
William said it's a lot of guys that hit
a wall they have to overcome a lot of
guys that had to play triple-a for a
couple years before somebody picked them
up a lot of them so is in business but
no matter what you're doing anticipate
the wall you're going to hit it and in
those moments whatever you tell yourself
if you convince yourself that the
difficult your face and is harder than
everybody else's and you buy it you will
stay where you're at
but if you convince yourself now
whatever you wall you've hit other
people have overcoming and so can you
you go through that wall wall as well
either way the choice is always going to
be yours